hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play don't starve
now this game was released recently on
April 23rd however people have been
playing the beta for quite some time now
so I'm pretty late to the game here but
I wanted to give it another try or
another try a try because it seems like
a really interesting and unique title
and I like the stylistic indie games
here so let's give it a go
shall we new game in character I only
have the one these are unknown and they
seem to be in coffins good crows a
magnificent beard how about a
magnificent moustache customized world a
let's just keep everything default here
because it's my first time obviously I'm
probably not gonna listen to the
namesake of the game I'm probably going
to die I imagine I've only seen minimal
stuff about this so as far as I know
hillo said Balor you don't look so good
you'd better find something to eat
before night comes huh what what was
that on my head I'll leave one of these
tasty birds Hey tasty birds come back
here found some seeds oh I can eat the
seeds like I said something hey bird I'm
trying to catch you butterfly flutter by
yep well it seems like the voices seemed
to be a little disturbed so Piney add
mushrooms
I could eat petals something tells me
that's it's probably not not a good
thing I wonder if it'll come back
possibly hmm okay so I really like the
way the animation style works with the
sort of pseudo 3d environment this is
actually really cool
like I said before I've never really had
a chance to give this a try
I don't think eating petals would be a
good thing well there I go red cap eat
carrot I don't feel so good oh well yeah
I'm pretty sure that it was probably a
bad thing I can't see the bottom we'll
jump right in can you drink from it no
idea okay so anyway there seems to be a
tool of some sort over here and some
bones better him than me okay
so I can pick up these rocks I don't
think I can eat the rocks
but at the same time you never know
until you try oh I can make stuff let's
see I've got a pickaxe which means that
I could probably do Flint gonna make
fire out of that but I'm the very sharp
rock and I'm betting if I combine it
with the stones maybe not haha once
again like I said I have absolutely no
idea what I'm gonna be doing so I'm just
gonna be trying to uh do random stuff
here and I'm about halfway through the
day already which means that I who is
that a giant rock I can mine the giant
rock yes
wait hit it harder yeah go up to this
one cuz I can't see what I'm doing
hit it hard whack it whack it good there
we go gold gold is there any one that I
can trade gold with or am I really gonna
make stuff it's kind of reminiscent of a
very different style minecraft which in
its way is really cool because there's a
lot of stuff you can do I mean um was
that other game the terraria it's like
you know there are a different type this
is a genre of game and I kind of liked
it but this one has a lot of a darker
theme to it now is it an ocean right
there can I jump into it can i leap into
it I don't want to live anymore please
just what is that what was that what
what the hell is that
this looks like a loves to hey hey hey
hey hey hey hey go away
I'm gonna steal your stuff I must deal
this no go no go away go away go away
ah it's gonna eat me it's gonna eat me
this is not how the food chain is
supposed to work I'm the tip top of the
food chain I'm a professional
he thinks that night is gonna be very
bad for me but then again I have no idea
I need more tools when I actually what I
need is like a fire some sort maybe I
could like I don't know how I use flint
and steel maybe I need actual steel
berry bush I could use some berries give
me give me give me
Edie Edie okay so I seem to be doing
relatively okay or if I'm not doing okay
I can't really tell my heart's at 131
201 35 I'm guessing that's my psyche
like my psychological impact of the
destruction coming across oh I almost
had you that time so far I'm not seeing
anything more than rocks and trees I
need another tool like an axe that I can
make something out of because I need to
get wood I'm guessing so that I can make
tools oh wait here we go see yeah I need
I needed I need an axe I can't get an
axe alright let's just keep with the
berries come on gimme gimme gimme there
we go ding rate it's getting late white
What did he say I did I missed it what
did he say he it's getting late
something his headstone is blank maybe
that's cuz it's my grave oh this does
not look good this does not look good
something tells me I'm not gonna survive
my first night what's with the gold
nuggets just but there's all sort of
good stuff down there or not or not how
about not seeds I'm just guessing that
as soon as night comes is gonna be
monsters because that's kinda long the
same vein as minecraft there when night
comes the monsters come out I mean in
its heart
at its heart minecraft in this game are
both survival games because in an
open-world game basically if you're left
to simulate life as it is life a big
part of life is just surviving so you
could say their survival games as well
anyway let's see if I can make a fire
nope don't have wood I don't have enough
stone or wood grass and sticks see all
these things I don't have enough of just
because I don't have any wood like oh I
could pick these saplings I'm so I'm so
done that'll teach him yeah you tell
that thing okay yeah oh okay
well this is my ignorance because I'm
not used to the game at all I have I've
done very little of it I saw those
saplings before and I walked up to him
but I didn't click enough take that
nature yeah it's right you tell that
nature it's been mean to you anyway chop
chop chop chop chop chop
see I wonder if I can make sticks out of
these logs maybe anyway I need to make a
fire no I can't cuz I don't have enough
grass uh oh this is not good what I can
get if I get one more stone and there's
one up there I can make a fire pit which
would probably be much better than what
I'm looking for here so let us make okay
that turns green let's put it right
there by that water there huh oh it's so
warm and inviting it actually does look
kind of nice haha I'm hoping that this
will keep some of the monsters away
although I have no idea okay so next we
need to go find some sticks but first
let's just chop down these trees by the
fire first because I don't want to go
out into the middle of the night they
could kill me nibble my giblets I don't
think my axe is gonna last much longer
okay down on the bottom right there it
says my axe has 60% durability so that's
actually better than I thought and if
you hold down the mouse button you chop
it up my fire my fire oh it just turned
at night okay so I do not want to be out
in this darkness for long so let's just
stay by the fire and just camp out the
fire is getting a bit low how do I add
wood to it can I just can I just chop
some wood in maybe possibly maybe please
can I chop this Boulder okay I might be
boned oh here we go at fuel yes Wow
let's get that thing burning look at
that
that's almost warm and inviting grass
I'm actually oh hang on guy have time to
get this stuff before you just go
wandering off what is this guy's name
anyway
William was that his name I'm not sure
come on chop it down the big baby
seriously what what lies in the woods
what awaits me in the darkness of my own
soul I'm hoping that if I'm kind of
edging into the darkness it doesn't just
sort of rip me apart that would not be
good okay
got that got that
got that I'm getting kinda well not that
hungry I'm actually doing pretty good
and I could eat leaves which would be I
guess nice
I can hear a try any tree inside of it
so let's plant some trees what
oh I survived the night haha wait a
minute hang on what happened
I didn't mean to plant all of those pine
cones or drop all of them no I dropped
just one plant oh I got to plant it on
the green well alright then nevermind
heck why aren't I able to plant it and
never mind
yeah way maybe hang on let me sink us
something I hold it down nope nope okay
so I don't know what the dealio is with
that but I need to go find some more
sticks to be able to make a pickaxe
because I need a lot more rocks there's
a berry bush down their breakfast hmm
I'm like Bear Grylls except I don't
drink my own piss well I mean not yet I
haven't resorted to that just yet okay
so can I pick up my campfire or is it
just is that my home base for now a lot
of rocks over here let me just collect
them up and what's with the Bricker is
that stone I'm not sure what that is
either way all right getting more rocks
getting more rocks need sticks so far I
did I'm actually really impressed by
because stylistically I haven't seen any
sort of game like this at all I mean I'm
really impressed ok um I need another
stick come here sticky dun dun dun got a
pickaxe why did I need to do that I have
no idea but I can make science now a
science machine actually hang on oh now
we're getting into the interesting
things let's make my home base over here
and then I could venture out from there
because I bet now that I see these Oh
Noah that's not what I meant to do can I
plant I probably need to make like a
hill or something I have no idea
I'm curious as to how in-depth this game
is because um it's said when I bought it
that there were a lot of um planned
updates to the game coming out regularly
and instead the next one was coming out
of like I don't know 17 days or
something like that so I'm actually
wondering what they have if it's sort of
like a
crafts style of sequential updates and
stuff like that science machine okay
cool
what is this done for me a crass suit
really a suit made of grass that is the
most ridiculous thing I've ever seen in
my life okay so I need to be able to
make a basic farm but you yeah all right
maybe I shouldn't have made my home base
this close to here where's my pickaxe go
anyway there it is okay let me use this
get some more rocks out of this tink
tink tink tink tink there we go all
right what's that night her for Zephir
explosives really cool bonk
okay rocks went Nider okay me tray mine
more gold punk do some gold for some
science projects up in here there we go
okay so what does it lose that weight
Pam was that magic magic what sort of
science relies on magic meat effigy
resurrect yourself with the power of oh
that doesn't make any sense what I have
no idea okay
alright anyway um so with that said I
shouldn't have made my home base there
because I don't know where I can go to
get other stuff in the day is almost
over
I am almost dead we're gonna get more
sticks I need a lot of sticks but I'm
not getting anything now I'm running out
of time oh there we go here we go okay
seems like everything's bunched up in
different places but you got to find the
bunches first or I just made my home
base in a really bad spot that has
nothing around it hey either way I'll be
able to make another campfire over here
if I need to just need to get as many
sticks as possible right now what's with
that big thing
a salt Oh getting dark getting dark
getting dark
let's make a fire pit okay Barsky Babu
put that in there and fuel that well
more so I can chop down these trees with
this but I'm running out of durability
on that but good thing I got sticks
I'm basically a professional at this
game already if you guys couldn't tell I
am so awesome
and everyone knows it I'm actually
running out of inventory space here I
don't know what to do anything new like
what do we do with us oh no I lost my
hey guys check it out on what video
chopped it down
wondering how I can kill those birds cuz
I'm getting hungry and I don't have any
food I mean I can't exactly eat a
pinecone I have seeds but III need to
make a farm a desperation calls for
desperate measures
I guess I could eat I don't know ketil's
yeah how'd you eat petals you okay come
her I want to kill you
come here bird dabble it okay let's just
try to mine whatever this giant thing is
up it's too strong to break through well
never mind then
god damn Birds get out of here this is
mine I'm gonna miss some religious
artifact yes
no mala ji okay anyway so we got our
fire burn in here it's not quite a night
yet so let's go grab some small stuff
like grass cuz I don't know where I get
manure Ivan I don't even seen any other
larger animals besides that big stick
legged bird thing whatever with the big
eye in a beak whatever it was it was
freaky okay so I can make a trap yes oh
I can make a trap that's perfect then I
can lay the trap like see I wove it
really tight set trap over here and that
means that if a bird I can chase a bird
into the trap maybe I don't know I don't
know what I'm doing I'm gonna starve to
death
even though the game told me not to bird
you want to go into the trap bird do you
want to you want to go into the trap
bird
hey wait baby cries bird dammit
he's Birds sons of [ __ ] I hate them
still they mocked me mercilessly it's
almost nightfall it's actually nightfall
right now right now it's nightfall I'm
thinking I'm thinking that the darkness
must have a psychological effect because
that must be what the brain is all about
but either way no time for that I have
more fuel to the fire and then we good
and then we just have to wait out the
night so well shut up
eat some seeds I'm having a personal
moment with my audience okay all right
we survived the name did you all survive
the night I'm not sure if you did but
anyway we're actually running out of
food my stomach is all shriveled and
doesn't look good and it's raining
fantastic this is just horrific well
like I said I didn't really expect to
get very far on my first try this but I
mean I learned a bit and learning is
half the battle or something like that
come on bird ah hey there's a mushroom I
bet that's gonna make me sick but at
least it's food nom nom that don't feel
so good
Saki top you baby okay so mushrooms they
give you hunger but they don't give you
they take away health I think what I
should have done in the beginning was
explore more and try to find a better
location to set up because I've sort of
just been wandering around in circles
without being able to and I dropped that
grasp oh that's what I
oh that little Jackalope here I should
have been it I should have been able to
put the trap on the rabbit hole that way
it comes out oh that's why I see I'm
learning I'm learning but unfortunately
now I am all out of time so I will try
this again if you guys would like to see
it if you guys would let me know in the
comments below thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I've done and as always
almost
you in the next video
[Applause]
[Music]